Tucker Carlson last night did a segment
on how Gavin Newsom the most evil when I
speak of evil reptilian lizard people
only Trudeau is even close uh well Gavin
Newsom is basically trying to make it a
crime to criticize Pfizer in California
yes really we've got video going away
now politicians in California were just
caught colluding with Twitter to censor
political critics
but instead of stopping the illegal
unconstitutional totally immoral
censorship Governor Gavin Newsom
designed a bill that will punish doctors
for the crime of disagreeing with Gavin
Newsom right because remember it's just
between you and your doctor but now
Gavin Newsom who's not a doctor there's
like a [ __ ] is somehow telling your
doctor what to think yeah
under this new law doctors can no longer
spread quote false or misleading
information regarding the nature and
risks of the virus that would be
coronavirus its prevention and treatment
and the development safety and
effectiveness of covid-19 vaccines
in which you're not allowed to criticize
Pfizer it's now a crime in California oh
shareholders of Pfizer anyone probably
okay so this is really extraordinary
stuff and this is a massive massive
escalation on the assault on Free Speech
which is just endlessly happening to us
virtually every day the idea that the
government of California would tell
doctors that they cannot you know spread
this misinformation well it's like well
how about all the doctors that for two
years said the vaccine worked and said
that there were no side effects and said
that everybody needed it and all of the
stuff with those people be punished and
then you see how the collusion with big
Tech works and how the government is
actually at some level now violating our
first amendment rights California passes
a law saying oh you the doctor can't
spread misinformation well now if the
doctor shares his thoughts on Twitter
and then evil Gavin Newsom or Joe Biden
or anyone from an Administration calls
up Twitter and Twitter takes information
down that is a violation of the first
amendment of your right to free speech
but that is what is happening in blue
States what happens in Cali export
reports to other blue States and as a
Floridian I'd like to say good luck with
all of that